[Music]
you did a movie called bad Milo yes and
bad Milo let me just explain the premise
of bad Milo a monster comes out of
someone's rear end posterior craftier
yes this and this is Ken Marino yes and
this I think we have a still here of you
confronting the monster oh yeah yeah
let's talk about this because yeah
you're very attractive you're very good
actress you're very very sharp why did
you sign up to do bad Milo just hate my
career just wanted it to be over
uh no actually that sort of project
really strangely appeals to me everyone
said did you have to be talked into this
I said no I heard it was about a butt
monster so you want you're basically
saying is you said to your agent you had
me at butt monster it's about a button
on so in any way you're going to get
hold it right there I want it and I
don't care whether shooting it and how
much I get paid is only where and when
my philosophy is ring ring hello I'll
take it so with that kind of a
philosophy you end up fighting a butt
monster right so I don't even want to
talk too much about the plot because can
we even on TV probably not yeah we can
sure yes yeah laughter no but wait and
so this this okay there's a butt monster
that's all you need to know the poster
the poster for it what so near and dear
to my heart
the poster yes the poster is okay okay I
have a love of cheesy 80s posters you
know call them tipping shades where
people are wearing like Ray Bans and
there and they're tipping them down a
little bit you guys tipping shades right
so they made a poster for this movie
where a bad Milo the butt monster is
riding a skateboard with some Ray Bans
and like has extra intestines flowing
behind him I think we have that this is
actually or I mean that to me is heaven
look if I'm in a movie that has a poster
where et made out of intestines is
wearing cool shades and riding a
skateboard you need a better team around
you
I have the wrong goal you certainly do